in January 2009 a person or group named
Satoshi Nakamoto uploaded a small piece
of free shared software to the internet
called the Bitcoin protocol and asked
others to copy and run it on their
computer think of this program as a free
virtual bank for the internet community
anyone is free to join and use it to
send and receive a new kind of virtual
coin to and from other account holders
it was driven by a problem people had
been trying to crack for 20 years how to
send cash in an electronic form over the
Internet the one thing that's missing
but that will soon be developed is a
reliable ecash the method we're buying
on the internet you can transfer funds
from A to B without a knowing B or B
knowing a the way in which I can take a
$20 bill and hand it over to you before
Bitcoin the only way to make electronic
payments over the internet was to call
your bank or a company connected to your
bank and ask them to move the money to
the other person however over two
billion people in the world don't even
have access to a bank account so you
simply cannot send money to them no
matter what value they have to offer
they are shut out of the internet
economy this is important because access
to financial services directly
correlates to increases in dignity
liberty and self-determination and even
those who do have a bank account aren't
exactly free to send money to anyone
anywhere online if two governments don't
get along money simply doesn't flow
across their borders simply put if you
wanted to give $1.00 right now to
someone via the Internet almost half of
the world can't receive it from you a
digital cash would connect humanity
economically in a way never before
possible in a way that included everyone
in the same way that cell phone
technology allowed entire nations to
leapfrog the
and line and achieve communications that
would be unthinkable Bitcoin can do the
same for banking and finance and it can
empower billions of people around the
world Bitcoin for the first time makes
possible transactions online that are
person-to-person without the need for an
intermediary between them just like cash
Satoshi offered a physical analogy for
Bitcoin to warm people up to the idea
imagine there was a metal as rare as
gold but it had one magical property it
can be transported over a communication
line like sending physical cash as a
direct message nearly instantly but
Bitcoin isn't a boring gray metal it's a
virtual coin taking the form of a number
[Music]
at first these bitcoins had no value at
all they were simply passed around for
fun by people who were interested in the
idea like digital tickets to affair
which didn't yet exist
gradually hobbyists collected and sold
bitcoins for a fraction of a penny just
to prove the system could work because
once Bitcoin had any value at all and
therefore a price it became a powerful
social technology this gave birth to a
new layer of Internet marketplaces which
didn't require or even allow traditional
money a new freedom had emerged Bitcoin
was being used by people who had nothing
to do with its creation and no
government could stop it though Satoshi
was always worried about Bitcoin growing
too fast from the start this was not
about making money it was about freedom
of exchange online this growing public
acceptance of Bitcoin and proof that it
worked
led to a secondary demand for Bitcoin as
it became viewed as a safe haven for a
portion of their savings which was
outside the hands of any government so
the demand for both transactions on the
network an investment in the network
pushed the price of one Bitcoin right
beside the price of an ounce of gold by
December 2013
gradually larger and larger institutions
adopted Bitcoin as a form of payment and
eventually forward-thinking governments
began to recognize
as a legal payment method I'm interested
in coming to learn what is needed to
ensure that this innovation can continue
I'm here to testify because I believe
that digital currency represents one of
the most important technical and
economic innovations of our time four
years later in December 2017 a
speculative wave pushed the price of a
single Bitcoin past 10 ounces of gold
but before getting to the method behind
how Bitcoin works the question most
people get hung up on is how can a
number have value why would anyone in
the right mind trading PSA's of gold for
a number
let's rewind for a moment and think
about money money is how we move value
across distance or through time within a
small trusted group such as a family you
don't really need physical money people
give each other things of value with the
promise to return the favor in the
future so money actually starts as a
shared memory the very oldest written
documents we can dig up show we often
wrote down a list of promises to each
other known as a ledger this is what we
call digital money money which takes the
form of written symbols or digits but
this kind of written money only works if
we trust the people we are making
promises with and so when humans travel
to distant regions to trade with people
they've never met and may never meet
again
they used physical money instead this
allowed them to settle trades
immediately with no trust involved and
of all the kinds of physical money we've
used throughout history there is one
pattern which emerges we ended up using
some form of treasure often a rare Rock
a typical rock at the beach won't work
nobody values them because they are so
plentiful but once in a while you will
find something more unique a shiny rock
a tooth a bone humans have a tendency to
collect and treasure unique things the
value of these treasures was based on
the fact that everyone knew they were
rare rarity is the value remember if you
were alone on earth the value of any
treasure wouldn't exist any more think
of this as symbolic value it may seem
strange to value rarity but we all
exhibit this phenomenon beginning as
children we value things that other
people have and we don't it can drive us
crazy it can mean everything
[Music]
until we find out there are many copies
of the same toy and it's no longer
unique suddenly others don't value it as
much and it becomes worthless garbage
and we do this exact same thing as
adults we value things based on
uniqueness or rarity nothing to do with
their actual utility throughout history
you'll see each culture uses their own
kind of rare rock as money in their
local region and treasure in one region
isn't always recognized as treasure in
another gradually as people begin
spreading around the world a global
treasure emerged based on the rarest of
rocks precious metals these are the
shiny bits people noticed in rocks all
over the world we extracted this shiny
stuff by grinding up the rocks melting
them down and pouring out only the shiny
stuff as pure metal and we give the name
precious metals to only the rarest of
metals
iron for instance is very useful almost
everything is built out of it but it
isn't considered precious because there
is so much of it around that's why one
ounce of iron is worth a few pennies
people only pay for its utility compare
this to one ounce of gold which is worth
over a thousand dollars that's all
driven by its rarity precious metals are
an important form of money because they
came to be valued everywhere on earth
they work as a physical money that
crosses all borders the value of an
ounce of gold is not dependent on any
one culture this explains why those in
power have always tried to hoard and
control gold it's a form of global
wealth
and so history is full of examples of
people in power collecting as much
precious metal as they could stamping it
into coins with the rulers face on it
and leaking it into society via wages
across cultures history shows that
gradually rulers realized the same thing
that the coins they pressed didn't need
to be so precious what was most
important about a coin was not the metal
content in it but trust in the number on
it but it was the Chinese who first took
this to its logical conclusion and put
it into practice in the 11th century
when they created a money supply out of
trusted numbers on paper with no
connection to gold or any precious metal
it's exactly like what happens at the
fair today money takes the form of
tickets because the Chinese realized
that the best way to control gold was to
force everyone to sell their gold at the
borders for a piece of trusted paper
money and like fair tickets you couldn't
go back and cash those pieces of paper
in for gold there was no link between
the paper and the gold your only option
was to spend the paper money in the
economy this was a brilliant scheme it
allowed the rulers to hold all the
global money such as gold while the
people carried a local money that's
circulated within their borders
eventually every country copied this
idea this results in the now modern idea
of government manufactured rare paper
known as fiat money paper money which
isn't connected or backed by gold or any
form of physical value it's printing is
decided by the government who is in
charge of controlling the money supply
and enforcing its use as long as people
remain confident that our government is
strong and secure
they will continue freely to accept and
spend its money without questioning the
value that's how we end up with a world
full of local fiat currencies which
travel freely within the borders of a
given country dollars euros yet they are
all the same thing each country is using
its own fare tickets with no connection
to gold or any precious metal and today
we rarely use paper money roughly 90% of
your money exists only in digital form
so today you mainly use number money
like points these points exist as your
bank account balances which are stored
with a bank in a trusted computer file
known as a ledger of accounts were
simply a ledger the government and banks
are in charge of creating securing and
censoring these numbers in the ledger
and that's digital money it's just a
ledger plus someone you trust such as a
bank to keep it up-to-date and secure
and this leads us back to the problem we
face online because the internet crosses
all borders and acts as a new global
community who is going to make the
digital tickets for the Internet and who
will we trust to be in charge of them
bitcoin is the world's first completely
decentralized digital currency and it's
decentralized part of that sentence that
is really unique the key to Bitcoin is
the way Satoshi flips the traditional
model of trust on its head instead of
letting a bank control a ledger you
share it with everyone anyone in the
world can plug in a computer to download
and track the bitcoin ledger known as a
Bitcoin node
this shared file model is more secure
than any government or bank ledger could
hope to be consider when a highly
controversial computer file leaks on to
the Internet
those in power learned that it was
simply impossible to stop alter or
destroy that file because there are so
many independent copies of that file
Bitcoin is one of a growing number of
systems that turns this openness of the
Internet into its security advantage but
a bank isn't just a ledger it's also the
people which validate and update new
transactions a bank is a process people
follow protocol and so you can think of
a bank ledger as a living document at
any moment it contains the history of
all balla transactions which define the
current account balances Bitcoin
automates this banking process with a
piece of shared software that all
Bitcoin nodes run called the Bitcoin
protocol it does the job of making sure
the history of transactions is secured
and so Bitcoin is a piece of shared
software which everyone runs together
instead of having one trusted computer
do it there is no Center to the network
no central authority no concentration of
power and no actor in whom complete
trust must be vested it's exactly how
ants and bee colonies function which are
naturally occurring decentralized
systems in this case a bee is like a
Bitcoin node they all follow the same
rules but collectively this results in a
high of being built the hive emerges
from the bees following rules Bitcoin is
like a computerized colony where instead
of building a hive they are building a
file which tracks the growing history of
valid transaction this file grows in
small chunks of new transactions
approximately every 10 minutes on
average known as the blockchain to best
understand Bitcoin you need to follow
how transactions get entered into this
blockchain
with Bitcoin all transactions are public
so instead of sending a private message
to your bank to move a number from one
place to another your computer shouts it
on a public internet channel which all
Bitcoin nodes are listening on two key
things happen once a transaction is
announced to the network first every
transaction should be heard by every
Bitcoin node in the network and secondly
every Bitcoin node must have a chance to
vote on whether a transaction was valid
or not to make both things happen
Satoshi did something very clever known
as proof of work the system slows down
the process by which new transactions
get verified by including an extra work
hurdle between when a transaction is
first detected at a Bitcoin node and
when it can be validated by the network
as follows
each node collects approximately one to
two thousand new unverified transactions
they hear in what's called a block next
this block of data is passed through a
symbol mixing machine which scrambles up
the data and spits out a short random
sequence of symbols associated with that
block it acts like an ID for that block
we call this mixing process a hash
function and we call the random output
the hash hash functions work in an
unpredictable but repeatable way the
same block of transactions result in the
exact same hash but if you change one
digit in the transaction block you get
an entirely different hash and for a
computer to perform this hash operation
on a block is very easy it can be done
in a fraction of a second but the
reverse operation is very difficult
because hash functions are designed to
mix the data in a way that makes them
practically impossible to
reverse-engineer
and this is the source of the extra work
because for every block the Bitcoin
software specifies the form the hash
must take which is a small number the
hash must be less than and is an
extremely rare occurrence and within
each block an extra space is included
before a number the Bitcoin nodes must
find which results in the desired hash
format to find the number which results
in the desired hash is like finding a
needle in a haystack of numbers the best
the Bitcoin node can do is rapidly
guessed numbers as fast as they can
until they find one which leads to the
valid hash format for any given block
and this is what Satoshi refers to as
mining it's a guessing game the first
computer in the network to find a lucky
number for a block is said to have mined
that block of new transactions and
immediately after mining a block that
lucky node sends it out to their
neighbors for confirmation essentially
saying hey everybody I won this race
please check that this block contains
all valid transactions and this brings
us to the second key rule all Bitcoin
nodes must follow as soon as a Bitcoin
node in the network creates or hears
about a newly mined block from a
neighboring node it stops and verifies
whether the block is valid or not
if the Bitcoin node finds any problem in
the block it simply ignores it and
considers it invalid if instead the
entire block appears valid then the node
downloads it to its memory of valid
transactions but instead of simply
downloading the block it actually
attaches to the block by calculating the
hash of that block and including it
within the next block of new
transactions they are working to mine
this is how a chain is created between
blocks which we call a blockchain it
creates an information dependency
between all blocks if you change one
symbol in any block within a blockchain
that change will propagate forward to
the very front so it locks the history
of all transactions in place and all
Bitcoin notes do this same thing they
either ignore a block if it isn't valid
or they attach to it if it is only after
every node in the Bitcoin network has
attached a block to the end of its
blockchain do we consider it as a valid
block this idea of voting on a block by
attaching to it is subtle but very
powerful because as soon as a node
begins mining the next block in a
sequence
it changes the growth rate of the chain
it's connected to and so as more Bitcoin
nodes work on guessing a given block
it's more likely that it will be found
sooner and so the chain will grow faster
as more nodes work on it and this leads
to the key insight behind Bitcoin the
true blockchain is the longest
blockchain because the honest chain will
grow the fastest and this allows many
disconnected people to agree on one
truth because let's say the majority of
nodes believe block a was the most
recent valid block while only a small
minority of cheating nodes believed in
Block B and to determine which is
actually the chain to trust the nodes
simply monitor which chain is growing
faster and because the majority has more
collective guessing power the chain
through block a will grow faster than
the chain through block B it's exactly
similar to why 10 people rolling dice
will hit on snake eyes faster than one
person over time one person might get
lucky and hit snake eyes once in a while
but over time the majority will always
hit snake eyes more often and this works
because no one computer or entity is
more powerful than the majority of
computers on the Bitcoin network
for comparison if Google dedicated all
its machines to mining Bitcoin it would
make up less than 1% of the total
Network power but this is all based on
one important assumption that the
majority of Bitcoin nodes will be honest
in the first place aside from doing it
out of goodwill Satoshi knew there must
be a fair economic incentive to motivate
as many people as possible to
participate in this network to do this
the Bitcoin protocol also rewards the
first node to mine a block with a small
payout of the initial Bitcoin supply
right now this payout is 12.5 bitcoins
and it's gradually decreasing towards
zero such that by approximately twenty
one forty all bitcoins in existence will
have been released or mind leading to a
precise supply of 21 million bitcoins
which will ever exist so the system pays
itself with the initial supply to grow
and secure itself so bitcoins come into
existence through the Bitcoin miners and
then they are spread around to the
general public via open markets or
directly from person to person and
that's how Bitcoin works they are
numbers that flow through a ledger that
everyone tracks together and to this day
nobody has been able to compromise or
attack this system even with hundreds of
billions of dollars on the line as
regulatory and law enforcement agencies
seek to apply existing laws to Bitcoin
they will face the challenge that
Bitcoin is not a company with an easily
identifiable executive but instead it's
an open-source project and a community
the first wave of the Internet in the
80s and early 90s resulted in a network
which connected humans globally in a way
never before possible
soon after the second wave of the
internet gave birth to massive networks
with billions of connected people that
were owned and controlled by a single
trusted corporate entity via proprietary
software
the idea behind Bitcoin and some say the
next wave of the Internet is to dissolve
that border and replace the trust
identity and proprietary software
with an open network running free shared
software which is available to everyone
and it's based on a new model where the
crowd takes control of the software we
use instead of a trusted third party the
question left in the wake of Bitcoin is
what's next what would your reaction be
to just a rapport with one
recommendation and that recommendation
would be that there be no regulations
and that we revisit this in say five
years I think that would be a very good
idea I think there is some room for
clarification clarifying for example the
tax status for individuals or at least
clarifying the right of an individual to
make a choice in the currency they use
as a consumer as entirely equivalent
with any other national currency in the
near future the Bitcoin protocol will
also facilitate advanced payment
services and experiments are currently
underway to provide additional
non-financial services like property
management and identity verification
you
[Music]